as a cinematographer how much gear do
you own varies sometimes i buy extra
things for a project and I hang on to it
other times i buy extra things for a
project and it gets destroyed I have
right now two or three cameras some
GoPros but I don't really use those that
often on projects that i'm doing like
feature films specifically and I've been
asked several times whether I want to
get in on a red camera with somebody or
own equipment that's very expensive and
tiny i'll try to rent it out and things
like that i guess i don't want to limit
my i feel like if i had a red camera
myself i probably limit myself to
shooting with the red camera all the
time and i think that would be a bad
thing because i could i would be
choosing that tool sometimes in
situations where wasn't necessary or it
wasn't the right camera for the job and
i think it's easy to kind of like
justify it by having to pay the bills
for it but i don't necessarily want to
be in the business of owning and renting
cameras i want to be in the business of
making movies and being a
cinematographer it's a totally different
business it's a whole other headache to
maintain something expensive like that
it's like having a Ferrari if something
goes wrong I mean expensive to fix you
know it draws a lot of attention and
when you're holding it or driving it
figure Ferrari you know it's just a
again as I said before like if you
choose you to spend your time on certain
things they will spend your time it's
time on you if I chose to spend my time
on a red camera and own it and to have
all the passes that went with that i
think i would probably get sucked into
that world a little more and have to be
dealing with rentals and all this kind
of a process which i don't necessarily
want to do as a person i'm not really
interested in that so you know i've had
the opp there's a possibility I might
have one available to me and possibly
partner up with someone on it but it's
not something that I would have to pay
for it would be as a like a
work-for-hire I'd be open to that
because then I wouldn't feel obligated
to use it on any given situation it
might be the right choice sometimes and
I probably would use it but I wouldn't
feel like oh crap I gotta pay my bills
on it and then try to figure out a way
to work it and do whatever project I'm
doing that's what I feel like would
happen if I had one or something like it
and I could Alexa or something like that
what are you thoughts on owning or
actually purchasing used gear you know
even from I wouldn't I probably
personally I mean I'm not sponsored by
anybody so I can say this i don't think
it's makes sense to buy a brand new
camera because it's like buying a brand
new car it kind of loses its value as
soon as it comes off a lot it's not a
good investment I don't think anybody
used one to get a good deal on it then
you're in good shape hopefully the last
you a long time and you know these days
it's a little bit weird because as
things are starting to shift over to 4k
so you're in a you know it's always that
there's always a weird sort of window of
time or it's a bad idea to buy used gear
because it's going to be too old in a
year or two but I think once things
start to come out that's all for K in
like 2-3 years after that then you can
start buying some of the old 4k cameras
and it's going to be fine because then
we're going to time change from the 10
years or 15 years after that and our
eyes can only see up to a certain number
of K so how many tell how many more
caves can they come up with I mean I'm
probably dating myself in this interview
by saying that right now probably
someday that'll be like 8800 gay and I'm
going to be
laughed at but I don't think it really
matters up to a certain point resolution
wise i mean i think 4k is already a
little bit overkill personally a lot of
the thumbs that i've shot that have been
released in theaters I've only been
projected in 2k and they look just fine
I thought 4k is pretty cool but I don't
see a difference personally but I also
don't have twenty-twenty vision as a
cinematographer it's kind of weird but I
only I have to wear glasses sometimes so
it could be just because I don't see a
difference personally but what about in
terms of editing though with 4k isn't
that going to be more sure it's more
processor intensive and all that and
takes a lot more space up but
everything's getting cheaper I mean a 8
terabyte raid tower that i have is only
a few hundred bucks whereas ten years
ago that was like a four or five
thousand dollar hard drive and it's all
going to get cheaper I mean as there's
more people owning report k cameras
there is going to be more demand for
more storage space so things are going
to go down prices just the way it is I
don't think it's going to be much
different than when SD turned to HD
people were like oh man there's so much
data they were so blown away by how much
data there was but really it wasn't
companies are really worried about it
today are there can you store stuff in
the cloud that's a little tougher still
Internet's kind of slow overall I think
you're part of that just cuz well the
cable companies run everything so they
control how fast everything is I think
fiber optics is pretty rad I've been
able to use it a few times and it's nice
because you can just upload stuff and
super fast right now i'm uploading
footage that I shot yesterday is 26 gigs
and then unfortunately this hope this
internet i have here is so slow it's
going to take like three days so i might
as well just drive over to my friends
house that is awesome internet and doing
like a few hours it just depends
you